coming up next book tv presents
afterwards an hour-long program where we
invite guests hosts to interview authors
this week acclaimed sas and author alain
de baton and his latest release religion
for atheists
in his book he argues that rather than
mocking religion atheists and agnostics
should steal the best ideas from world
religions such as the methods for
building strong communities overcoming
envy and forging a connection to the
natural world
the philosopher essayist discusses his
concepts with former seminarian and
author chris hedges
ellen i wanted to ask you first sort of
broadly about the vision that you put
forth in religion for atheists which is
a kind of
utopian sort of look at or or
restructuring or reformation of
secular society and i thought maybe just
sort of broadly you could lay out
some of the ideas in the book
i suppose my starting point is secular
society has not worked everything out in
other words once we reject religion if
we reject religion
we still have some gaps there are some
problems with the way secular society
runs
and it struck me that many of these gaps
could best be understood through the
prism of religion that we have
secularized i say in my book we've
secularized badly in the sense that
we've thrown out a lot of stuff
which was associated with religion um
and which is now absent from
contemporary secular life but which we
would do well to revisit so what i do is
um look systematically through
three faiths christianity buddhism and
judaism asking myself always one
question what here might we use what
here might inspire is there stuff here
that we've left behind that we could in
giving up the doctrinal side of religion
nevertheless have benefited from that's
my starting point and so i look at areas
like community education ethical
structure
art and architecture the notion of an
institution which of course the faiths
are
and a few other things besides
and you have some sort of very specific
proposals
you know examples from religious life
that you essentially would like to see
secularized
and incorporated into the wider society
perhaps you can sort of expound upon
some of those sure well one of the areas
that i look at is education and it
strikes me that religions are in a way
giant educational machines um now in the
secular world we take education really
seriously um
and a lot of money is devoted to
institutes of higher education
when people are trying to understand why
we educate um one answer is skills for
jobs for the economy you know to compete
to be a competitive economy that's
simple enough but there's another
more
noble sounding ambition which creeps in
during the more lyrical passages of
politicians speeches or graduation
ceremonies and that's the idea that
education should be a source of guidance
that it should help you to live that it
should be
an education of your soul
it should help you to find meaning
consolation
ethical structure
in other words that's quite a religious
ambition and in my book what i do is i
trace it and i say that started in the
19th century as church attendance began
to collapse in many parts of western
europe people ask themselves the
question
how are we going to replace many of
these good things from religion ethics
structure meaning
and an influential group of people like
matthew arnold and john stuart mill came
up with what i think remains a really
intriguing idea they said culture will
replace scripture culture the capital c
the plays of shakespeare the dialogues
of plato the novels of jane austen in
these texts in these works there are
possibilities for replacing a lot of the
direction and ethics and structure of
organized religions now i think it's an
intriguing idea it's also an idea that
has totally disappeared i mean if you
pitched up at a modern university say
you went to harvard or cambridge
university or oxford and you said you
know the reason i'm here is that i want
to learn how to live and die i want to
know what's good and bad i want to find
meaning i want to cope with my own
mortality
you know the guys would be dialing the
number for the insane asylum it's simply
not an ambition that we're allowed to
bring to bear
upon secular education
and i think the reason for that is
there's an idea that basically people
are
once and once you're an adult you're
kind of together
you know you don't need particular help
um the business of life is simple you
you know you need to get married and
have a family and find a job you love
and watch your parents die and confront
your own mortality and then put yourself
in a coffin but basically all of that is
easy you kind of you kind of know how to
do it if you're an adult
and the only people who need help are
stupid people and they read self-help
books that's the kind of dominant
secular elite ideology so the idea of
relevance and assistance and didacticism
is absent now if you look at religion
religions start from a completely
different point of view their view is
we're all of us only just holding it
together we are desperate we are
vulnerable and we need assistance right
through every stage of life
we need wisdom
and i don't necessarily agree with the
wisdom that is on offer through
religions i agree intermittently but i'm
fascinated by the analysis of our
fragility i think that's fascinating and
true
truer than the secular model
and that leads me to think that if i was
the emperor of all space and time i
would want to re-jig
how
wisdom is transmitted down the
generations
i would argue that the humanities should
go back to that 19th century vision that
neo-religious vision of using culture a
scripture i think that remains a very
good idea
sadly neglected so that's where i'd be
more than neglected probably assaulted
um if you look i i certainly within the
united states we now only have
a hundred thousand
college graduates a year majoring in any
branch of the humanities yeah um all of
these institutions like harvard neo
began to train ministers
they made that transition the one you
referred to as expounded by arnold and
mill
but
you know
in major universities department's
philosophy departments are being shut
uh university of uh albany just shut
down all their foreign language
departments their classics department
um
in some ways didn't that experiment fail
yes i think the fault is i mean often
people say um
you know the world is crass and
materialistic and the fault for this is
you know governments or horrible donors
or stupid students you know etc i have
to say with respect the fault really
lies in the humanities themselves
that they have failed to properly make a
case for their importance their vision
of scholarship has unfortunately been
hijacked by
a sort of neo-scientific idea that
research is what matters and that one
can research you know poetry like one
can research a scientific problem and um
this has put generations of students off
that the humanities have committed
suicide by
being so cut off from the questions i
mean it's extraordinary when you think
about it
there is enormous innate interest in the
question of how to live i mean it's
everywhere the idea that the humanities
departments have reached the stage where
they are so cut off from the spontaneous
curiosity of people that they're having
to shut down the problem lies with these
departments they have simply failed to
analyze the needs of their audiences and
to realize that the material they're
sitting on the culture they are sitting
on is a resource to live by and that if
they handled it like that
their departments would be opening
rather than closing this is harold
bloom's argument i don't know if you've
read any of his stuff on the western
canon
and of course he faults
the academic hierarchy itself
which i think you're doing yeah they've
brought it upon themselves i feel sorry
for them many innocent people are you
know being sacrificed in the name of
this corrupt ideology but um you know we
all know it you know it there is
appetite out there uh for
knowledge wisdom
structured argument etc and yet weirdly
it goes on outside the university the
university has which should have been
the center it should have been our
monasteries it should have been the
place outside of the press of capitalism
where the best arguments could be made
and rehearsed and wisdom taught and
transferred that dream and it really is
a dream it's dream written into the
architecture of america's colleges for
the most part that dream has been
betrayed and they're paying a financial
price and while i'm sorry i can only
think they have brought it upon
themselves well bloom bloom would argue
that
for those who truly
grasp as you point out the importance of
art and literature there's no place for
them anymore within the university these
people have to exist outside the
universe i think you would sort of agree
with that that's right um yeah the
problem is of course they are
disorganized and then weak and one of
the things that religion teaches us is
if you want to get something to have
power in the world you need to organize
you need to self-organize so you know
the problem of the lone
you know would-be academic in their
bedroom writing a book
you know it's much weaker
and if you look at how powerful
religions are it's because of their
capacity to organize themselves properly
and it was that mill and arnold's dream
was the secular world will organize
itself around the universities
it's failed to do that
and so you propose
to create new institutions
well i certainly propose a method of
rescuing our existing ones uh
recreating departments along you know it
seems striking to me that the
departments in higher education all
reflect academic disciplines rather than
questions of the soul so you have a
literature department which is a
completely nonsensical category
really what a literature department is
is a literature of is a department of
human relationships that's really what
it's about so let's have the department
of human relationships unless other
departments of loving and dying not the
department of anthropology or whatever
so the fact the academic discipline
comes first is part of the sickness of
the university it's part of putting the
cart before the horse
i want to talk a little bit about
institutions here i grew up in the
church and as i was telling you before
you're
although an atheist far kinder to the
institution than i would be
um
you
have a kind of healthy respect for
institutions
there is certainly a strain within
uh christian thought that argues that
with constantine the third century the
rise of the christian church
did as much to pervert and distort and
deform the radical message of the gospel
as
perpetuated yeah
i think i think we have to be careful
because certainly the temper of the
modern world it's a protestant idea
is that the institution is corrupt that
true religion resides in the individual
heart and that any agglomeration of
people is is corrupt while that's no
doubt true at certain points
it's also true that we have to
understand what is good about
institutions which is that they're able
to agglomerate money power intelligence
and can simply have a reach that the
individual will never have so um you
know i'm aware that in the secular world
there are lots of people trying to
change the world by writing books right
writing a book is the dominant method
and we found atheists writing books to
attack religion for example so you know
dawkins hitches et cetera they want to
bring that bring religion down so what
do they do they write a book problem
about writing a book is that you're
using one instrument to deal with
something which is utterly unsuited to
being attacked by that instrument a book
can't do very much because what you're
dealing with with a religion is an
institution which is
a book of course books are central to
religions but religions are also
community centers uh educational
machines um travel agencies music halls
uh you know
they're involved in so many different
activities and to think that a book can
sort of sharply and sarcastically just
blow this whole thing up is is to
misunderstand what you're dealing with
and um
as i say i think that
we're not short of very good ideas in a
secular humanist world the problem is
those ideas generally don't have
traction and they don't have traction
because they are not part of an
organized system so for example we have
lots of professors and people writing
wonderful books about ethics how to live
an ethical life lots of stuff
and yet you know go outside in the
streets of new york now is it happening
no why is it not happening because there
is not that thing that religions are
masters at which is the union of theory
and practice that's what's fascinating
to me about religions they are unified
uh things so that they have a branch of
them sit some uh intellects in in a
corner and gets them to write the books
but then there's also a group of people
who will be producing wood cuts that can
be read by anyone or we're producing you
know advertising billboards now in the
modern world or building cathedrals and
and it's a kind of it's what the germans
would call a gesund kunstfer a total
work of art
it isn't work of art as such but it has
that element of totality it's basically
saying to people we're not just trying
to access you through your brain through
your reason through you know your
intellect we are going to touch you at a
variety of moments in the day through a
variety of media
and
the secular world doesn't seem to
recognize that you know we've got
advertising and
the luxury industries and um the
construction industry on one side and
then we've got the intellectuals in in
another what you have to understand
about religion it's a union of those
it's it's construction and it's fashion
and it's music and it's the intellect
all as one embedded pushing one thing um
and i think this point is often missed
to what extent does
the consumer society and you talk in the
book about
public relations and uh selling i think
you talk about them sort of catering to
people's needs but of course what
they're actually doing is catering to
their emotional deficiencies that's
right that's right i mean there's always
that classic distinction in greek
philosophy between needs and desires and
that to lead a good life you have to be
able to distinguish those appetites in
you which are legitimate and linked to
serious need from those which are vain
and flighty and and evanescent linked to
your fugitive desires and that part of a
good life is knowing how to separate
that we've lost that sense
that we need help in doing that i mean
the consumer society is based on the
idea
that the individual can make up their
own choice the individual is robust they
can make the difference between needs
and desires maybe little children can't
so before seven o'clock or something you
maybe can't show a certain kind of
advert but basically adults will be able
to judge their true needs so you can
have a massive poster in front of them
saying go to thailand on holiday and be
happy and it won't have an effect at all
that's why we can have these posters of
course the advertising industry
recognizes that it does have an effect a
huge impact that's why advertising is a
business um
so but then of course the next logical
step is to ask well what are we doing
allowing a system to take place which
willingly confuses needs and desires
and therefore um prevents us from
possibly accessing our best
possibilities helps us to ruin our lives
um and religion is rather an interesting
kind of model because really what it
says is you do need advertising all
around but you need the right kind of
advertising you need reminders of how to
live well because we're permanently
being pulled in different directions and
that's how a lot of organized religions
function that they they have billboards
literally whether that billboard is a
cathedral or a temple uh or or it could
actually be a billboard it it's it's an
attempt to say you need some support the
whole of religious art is really an
attempt to support a set of ideas it's a
kind of propaganda it's a massive tool
to propagandize on behalf of some ideas
isn't it also a way to delineate space
between the sacred and the profane
um
yes
to create
an area where you will take time out
from your normal life in which the
values that are most close to your heart
and close to the truth can get a full uh
chance to express themselves this is
yes this is the sacred space this is the
cathedral the church the temple the
mosque you withdraw from the hub of the
city and you're back with your true self
um and again you see if i look at that
my first question is to say okay what
are we doing with that need now where's
that need gone now you know if this was
a serious need taken seriously by
religions for thousands of years where's
it gone what are we doing with it and
you know people would say well there's
the museum um to which well in my book i
argue quite a lot about why museums are
not quite doing their job properly so
there are many many ways in which stuff
that religions are quite aware of in
terms of our inner needs have gone
unattended in the secular world
there are certainly religious scholars
who would argue that and of course
religious systems are
created by humankind and oftentimes
serve
the interests
not so much of
religious tenants but for those who run
them the history of the catholic church
is a pretty sordid one
what about those
sort of critics who would say well
religion itself or institutional
religion
is uh to quote the theologian tylic
inherently demonic including the church
and that
oftentimes religious institutions serve
as much as an impediment towards the
capacity for transcendence or
transformation
um that that the religious impulse that
that those
uh those yearnings to describe
articulate and honor the non-rational
forces in life
beauty grief the struggle for our own
mortality all things that you've written
about
that
that one has to make a very sharp
distinction between the institutions
and the religious impulse and
in many cases and you know i covered the
war in the form of yugoslavia
the religious institutions signed on for
the crusades of ethnic cleansing i mean
they were they they lent their they gave
a kind of sacred
authority to murder
look um without wishing in any way to
underplay the terrible role of
institutions um
we also have to accept that institutions
can make things possible that are not
possible when it's just the individual
and i think maybe to take the heat out
of the out of the argument it helps to
look at other areas other than religion
where many of the same things happen i
mean take the arts and the humanities
we've been discussing it
the the university as a system um has
the same kind of relationship between
uh the spontaneous inner impulse and the
system so take take the impulse to read
poetry
um you can read poetry on your own and
you can have some wonderful feelings
private feelings very pure feelings um
then you can go to an institution you
have a terrible time they'll corrupt
your understanding of poetry they'll get
involved in departmental struggles
they'll misappropriate funds they'll
abuse students there'll be sexual
scandals um and the institution will be
horribly kind of corrupt right so you
have the same kind of dichotomy the
purity of the individual response the
the perversion and corruption and
violence and greed of the institution
this is not just a religious issue this
is a human issue
now how we to look at that um
my answer is neither one is the perfect
answer that you need both and that both
can go wrong you can have the personal
response that goes wrong because it's
not properly guided because it has no
traction because it just
is too it's squeezed out by the
pressures of life so actually you don't
read the poetry your religious impasse
is squashed because you're watching
television you know or whatever so you
know let's not romanticize the
individual genius spontaneous you know
person on the hill who feels alone
and at the same time while respecting
the terribleness that can afflict all
institutions all you know businesses
churches uh et cetera um
they are nevertheless able at their best
moments to do extraordinary things like
build a cathedral like commission in a
box mass in b minor or heathrow's
terminal 5 or the airbus a380 you know
in other words when humans come together
to do big things um
the result can be very impressive but of
course it can also be destructive so i
think we should stop being obsessed with
religion as an anomaly
in the corruption that afflicts it
it is no more or less prey to corruption
as an institution than any other human
institution and if you look at the
history of you know general motors
compared to the history of the catholic
church now history of general motors
only going a few you know decades um but
even in those decades you will find just
as much you know venality corruption
abuse um you know terrible stuff in the
history of general motors as you will in
a in a representative chunk of the
history of the catholic church now
spread the history over hundreds of
years and the catholic church starts
looking really bad but it has been going
for hundreds of years so let's beware of
um romanticizing the individual and
demonizing the institution both have
their problems
although general motors
i mean you could say that you know it
certainly embraces the ideology of
capitalism but it doesn't
uh
and and you're right i mean you look
back certainly before the reformation
the catholic church was a totalitarian
entity
which ruled as much through fear
and the threat of damnation
as anything else
that there was
a kind of power especially in
pre-literate
europe
which the church certainly abused but
these were violent times and you know
compared to the power that existed
during in you know in in normal
government at that time i mean this was
a the violence ruled in families this
was an age when
you know children couldn't answer to
their parents where wives didn't exist
as legal entities um where the whole
notion of being a subject was not part
of the common law so i mean we're
dealing with violence right across the
board and to say you know the church in
1400 was a bastion of intolerance you
know that's to narrow i mean i mean look
i'm an atheist i don't know i don't see
why i should spend my time defending the
catholic church but
all i'm saying is let's say i'm also a
historian and i know that you know set
in its context
you know the average monastery was not
better or worse than the average uh
kingship so you know let's set that you
know these were violent days let me ask
you about you you quote spinoza you
quote nietzsche and at one point in the
book you
uh
talk about how difficult which of course
is true
uh radical intellectuals those uh
figures like spinoza or nietzsche who
challenge an entire system
superstructure the assumptions of an age
uh
both essentially cast out uh not only by
the institutions i mean espinoza was
tried and denounced as a heretic um
and you i wonder if those figures can
ever
be comfortable in any institution um you
seem to propose that it's possible
well i you know reading about
nietzsche's life he longed for company
he looked back to ancient greece and
rome and the fellowship of philosophers
at that time epicurus and his garden
held a huge layer for him he wanted to
be he wanted to be part of a team
but he was living in 19th century europe
in the german university system
which um
you know was even less tolerant than the
university system now but it's you know
along similar grounds they didn't
recognize that they had in their midst a
top quality thinker and didn't give him
a job would he have wanted a job he was
desperate for a job he didn't want to be
an outcast at the top of a mountain um
you know speaking his claims to an
audience of four
uh he wanted to be a professor at basel
university but he was kicked out so you
know we should be aware of interpreting
a romantic view that um you know people
like nietzsche you know just wanted to
be on their own because it's it's nice
to live out of a suitcase roaming around
europe you know no um it's really great
to be the professor of x or y but so
long as you can say what you want to say
and that's what nietzsche himself dreamt
of
oh that's true but i wonder whether
institutions
have ever embraced
thinkers who
have sort of dynamited
the entire superstructure on which
social political and economic
assumptions are based i mean marx would
be another example i i it again it gets
back to that sort of conflict between
individual morality as niebuhr rights no
institution can ever achieve the
morality of an individual because
finally institutions are always
concerned about their own perpetuation
and their own survival whereas an
individual is capable of making a choice
and sacrificing that sure but i think
you know there are institutions which
better or worse address the needs of the
individual and i think that's really
what interests me you know when i look
at we're talking about the humanities
and how they're not particularly
addressing the needs of their students
and that's why people don't want to
study there you know that's the people
voting with their feet take another
institution like the world of museums
you know and you often hear it said that
nowadays
churches museums are our new churches
there are new cathedrals and what's
going on there what people are saying is
these are institutions where you will
find the same solemnity reverence and
enrichment for your soul as you might
have gone to religions for now when i
look at that i think well that's kind of
interesting good in theory and then i go
to the museum and i think
i'm not sure this is all going right
because i think again the museum has
fallen prey to a method of
presenting its art that is too cut off
from the lessons of religion religions
use art in a very simple way they use it
as a way
of
helping us to know how to live it's a
reminder religious art is a reminder of
how we should live an expression of
gratitude uh and a warning for you know
all sorts of ways in which we shouldn't
live um
that sounds really odd when compared
with you know what might be going on at
the museum of modern art or whatever um
we don't expect that art
should
have much of an intention upon us that's
the modern curatorial system modern
curatorial system is put objects in a
white space
put a minimal caption and you know get
the crowds through but really this is
not revolutionary either at the level of
the individual or of society in general
it exists in the world of art and so
writing my book i was struck by the way
in which
religions as institutions use art in far
more adventurous provocative ways
and it's just one example of how i see
you know lessons that can be pulled out
of religion by a non-believer and
applied to try and get some of things in
the modern world to go a little bit
better and yet the renaissance was
a reaction to the restrictions placed
upon art i mean voted shelley chill it
on everyone else yes well i think what's
interesting about the renaissance is
that it it kept true to
the didactic ambition of religious art
and indeed roman and greek art because
roman greek art is exactly like
religious art it wants to guide you and
know how to live which has been an
anathema under
the church roman and greek art yes
absolutely but but that ambition that
art should be a guide to life is is
there both in christianity and in pagan
thought and it only disappears in the
19th century under that rather unhelpful
idea that art should be for art's sake
and the idea that the artist is alone
figure who creates works that are
ambiguous and so that the dominant
feeling you get leaving the museum is
what did that mean
you know
you know and the the catalogue seems
like it was translated badly from the
german in other words you you're not
quite sure what your response should be
that is the modernist elite view of art
art is an ambiguous uh a medium and the
more complex a work of art the harder it
will be to say what that work of art is
about but you know religions you know
take a rembrandt uh painting like christ
crossing the sea of galilee it's a piece
of propaganda it's a very simple piece
of propaganda it's a propaganda on the
part of on behalf of courage basically
you're supposed to look at that and
remember what courage is
and it's very complex as a work of art
in terms of its technical formal
qualities but it's very simple at the
level of its moral
and
that's uh
that's a situation that we have a hard
time accepting in the modern world you
know how could something both be really
simple morally and yet really
complicated and some noble
as a work of art we we expect that you
know that's not going to be the case
although secular artists did it picasso
with guernica goya yep
yes i mean absolutely you see some
artists and the greatest artists i think
absolutely have that i think the problem
weirdly is not the artists it's the
system in which they operate you know
mark rothko take mark rothko um
fascinating artists very didactic
impulses um i remember going to see
rothko's paintings at the tate gallery
in london as a teenager thinking i
wonder what this is about wonder what
it's for i can sense a mood and it's
kind of powerful but i looked at the
caption and it just said mark rothko
american abstract expressionist born in
died in i didn't really know what it was
all about read some books on him didn't
really get a sense and then years years
later i read an interview with him which
the interview said what are you trying
to do with your art and he said i want
my art to be a place where the sadness
that is common to all of us can find a
refuge and a focus i thought wow that's
that's pretty simple you could write
that on a postcard do i do i ever see
that on the museum caption no i mean
it's anything but
and you find that with a lot of artists
you know you know if you said picasso
what are you doing with gwanika he would
say i'm trying to stop war i'm trying to
get people to be nice to each other but
when you go to the picasso museum is
that ever stated no picasso was
influenced by this and the inferno
so in other words that very simple
didactic ambition of the artist has been
drained out of it
by the curatorial system so i say that
the museum world does to the visible to
visible culture what the academic world
does to written culture which is namely
drain it of its revolutionary
therapeutic didactic possibilities
i would have to add that that's what
religious institutions
do to religion interesting interesting
um
perhaps because i'm an atheist um
i don't notice that as much
i'm more impressed by the aspects of
religion which seem only to be possible
through
a collective action but you know i defer
to you in this area strikes me that what
and it's also
an admiration that i share
that what
moves you
is not
always so much the institution but the
ritual yes yes and and rituals are
designed to create sacred space
they are designed uh
to
uh honor a reality that goes beyond
articulation
they are designed and i think is this is
also something you raise in the book
they are designed to put human beings in
their place within the cosmos
and and that of course is the power
there there is uh
um
something brilliant about the eucharist
and the mass i mean the way i look at it
is the ritual is a communal event
it it a ritual is something that that a
number of people do
that has an impact on the inner self and
again in the modern world we imagine
that things that happen in your inner
self come spontaneously or with
communion with with
one book uh or maybe one artwork in
other words there's the group doesn't
touch your soul
um and i think what's fascinating about
ritual is that it it it's precisely an
attempt to say
um left to your own devices solely
there are things that you're not going
to get to so we need you know
you're not going to forgive people
without yom kippur
you're not going to look at the moon
without the zen buddhist festival of
tsukimi uh you're not going to properly
forgive
people without you know the jewish
ritual of plunging yourself in a mcfare
or whatever that there are these
communal rituals which are gonna have to
take place um otherwise uh your soul
will be will be in trouble and i'm
deeply impressed by this um
chiefly because
subjectively i know there's so much that
i feel and want to do that i don't do
because there is no
communal structure and when people say
yeah but you know the world you know us
atheists we're brilliant at inventing
things and i've had that people say that
to me and i say oh really great what is
it and they go what we've got birthday
parties and i go come on the birthday
party go yeah you know i went to a 50th
it was great people read poems and
whatever and okay what's wrong with of
course there are secular rituals but
they tend not to be structured properly
they tend not to be psychologically rich
you know take something like um father's
day or mother's day which
is a secular ritual has obviously a
religious antecedent but it's a
typically modern secular rather stupid
ritual the reason it's stupid is that it
fails to recognize the number one thing
which is that we don't only love our
mothers or fathers we also hate them
they've let us down in all sorts of ways
that the relationship between parent and
child is conflicted and by having a
moment which only honors the positive
it actually makes
a true relationship impossible so a more
intelligent
relationship but more intentional ritual
would start by saying that relationship
is conflicted so we need the ritual to
accept that and that's what's clever
about things like well things like the
bar mitzvah the bar mitzvah if you
follow a bar mitzvah ceremony it's full
of acknowledging the fact that the
parents are sad that the kid is growing
up
it's basically saying
the kid is murdering the father right
this is a ritual murder of the father as
the next generation grows up so beneath
the festivities and the balloons and the
party and the presents what you've got
is an intergenerational you know murder
and but it's healed and it's held
together and it's done intelligently and
so that for me is the genius of
religious ritual well it expresses and i
you i think point this out at the
beginning of the book
a fundamental truth about existence
in the same way that the greek myths
understood psychological truths it's why
freud kept going back to greek myths and
shakespeare yeah
and
uh
and i think that i think i'm certainly
in complete agreement with you that
uh to ask the question is this literally
true
is absurd from the beginning because
even biblical literalists are
selectively
you know uh they're selective
literalists they they pick and choose
what they want um the
innumerable contradictions even within
the four gospels uh you know on all
sorts of issues and i think it's also
it's leaving the individual with so much
pressure to assume that we as
individuals can
do all the stuff we need to do just by
ourselves you know um i was struck in
reading the history of religions is
there's always in all religions a
festival of chaos a moment when the
world is turned upside down when power
relations are reversed when sexual
relations are reversed and when in a
sense all the craziness all our
perverse impulses a given room
for expression um and you know whether
it's carnival or you know the feast of
fools or in ancient greece the festival
of dionysus um or whatever it's a moment
in the calendar where the darkness is
allowed to come out into the light and
is regulating that's what that's what
fascinated nietzsche in in the festival
of dionysus that it's both chaos and
structure it's that wonderful mixture
and in the modern world what do we do
when we get drunk on a saturday night
and beat someone up or break a car or
something it's very
dis uncoordinated or we have an affair
and you know
it's it's it's left up to the individual
it's not cold it's not lent dignity it's
not seen as something that we all labor
with so the individual comes to their
own realization oh i've got unfaithful
impulses or oh i've got violent impulses
or oh i want to punch my boss and and
and this is seen as a private
realization against the backdrop of a
kind of sunny optimistic version vision
of man religions are much kinder to us
in saying of course this stuff's going
to be in you so we're going to try and
structure it we're going to give it a
bit of a place in in the world well it
acknowledges the dark impulses right
within humankind which of course in the
happy
cheerful positive psychology world of
modernity is completely denied right
which is what i mean what i love about
uh all the faiths is their pessimism you
know christian pessimism is wonderful
you know whether it's pascal or uh you
know in judaism you know the book of job
or uh buddhist texts that again speak of
the unitable you know misery of
the grasping of human nature these
things are incredibly important to read
precisely because we live in this sunny
world where the assumption is that
children are normal creatures rather
than half crazy beasts and that all of
us are mature you know sensible people
just looking forward to the next
vacation rather than people who are you
know torn apart by serious darkness and
i love reading
christian and other you know jewish dark
texts precisely because um i think oh
i'm not alone here there's some you know
this has been it's also very dignified
there's you know the the prose or the
poetry is beautiful the language is
beautiful so it expresses those most
private inarticulate sides of ourselves
raises them out of the darkness places
them before us and makes us feel less
lonely with some of the most
unacceptable stuff that you know resides
in the human soul well there was no
division between art and religion when
it began that's right and and i think
there should be no longer a division
between art and what i call psychology
the psyche that that division that that
art served the needs of the soul
directly with no it didn't exist in up
the art world it was just it was part of
ethics it was part of living um whereas
we've we've put it seriously in a corner
and we almost don't recognize how much
we put it in a corner but it's not it's
not in the service of life
and yet
uh you know both of us love proust
certainly for me gave me a language
gave me a vocabulary to describe aspects
of human reality that i had not had
before i read proof absolutely but you
know it's not the artist the artists are
doing a fine job it's the way they're
presented i mean i read a book a few
years ago on proust how proust can
change your life and that got me
excommunicated from the university i was
in
uh the the feeling was this is not a
serious man if he has written a book or
how bruce can change your life we don't
want him here he has written a self-help
book and i was happy to go because i
thought we're not seeing eye to eye here
but it's symptomatic it's not proof
that's the problem it's the structure
that we place around prus
everything all works of culture should
be how x can change your life how
picasso can change your life how
mondriyan can change your life you know
that's a method um that we've lost at
our peril but more importantly it's why
they wrote it i mean the last book and a
half of proust is one depth charge after
another absolutely this is a man looking
for the meaning of life and defining
if you like a quasi-religious path to
redemption and and and he who knew a lot
about religion is precisely following
you know in
absolutely
um
you have some sort of specific ideas
um i want to ask you about travel agents
and i mean i don't need to list them
agape restaurants but maybe you can sort
of spell some of them out well one of
the things i do in my book um
is provoke the reader into thinking look
what i'm telling you here is not merely
a set of ideas i'm trying to imagine how
we might tweak the world and change the
world with the help of
certain of these concepts that we've
been discussing
why do i do that i think there's sort of
an assumption that practice is in one
area and books are in another and the
books shouldn't suggest practices
and because i'm writing about religion
which are all about the union of
practice and theory
it seemed exciting and interesting to uh
look at that so for example i'm thinking
about perspective and or all the major
faiths are interested in the feeling of
awe
they realize that if you put somebody in
a space where they see how small a human
occupies
um so we'll be
how small a human being occupies in the
vastness of space or time
there will be
a kind of quietening of their soul their
anxiety their pressure to succeed and
their ego driven impulses that will
abate under the night sky
in a cathedral
in a grand canyon wherever it is you
will have a certain kind of feeling a
stilling of the ego the or uh the
feeling of all um so i try and think
okay religions are unparalleled at doing
this they do this all the time and
they're really great where do we do this
you know and people say okay we do go to
the grand canyon et cetera but i try and
imagine structuring it a bit more the
stars and astronomy is a vital source of
awe problem is when you go to a science
museum they'll they'll treat you like
you're a scientist they know they don't
treat you like you're looking for ore
they look treat you like you're you know
about to work for nasa and are seriously
interested in the details of the g102
galaxy you know three million light
years away you're not most of us are not
we're looking to use
science or scientific material as our
religious forebearers did in other words
as a source of ore but the modern museum
doesn't allow that so i try and imagine
a space where we might go that maybe
maybe a little bit like a planetarium or
a little bit like a science museum
where the point would not be to learn
learn about science it would be to look
at scientific phenomena for that feeling
of awe and its benefits that it can
bring i even playfully imagined that
these giant screens in times square that
are currently displaying the stock
market data would every now and then get
a live feed from the hubble telescope
that surrounds the earth and so that as
you're walking along uh you know mired
in the human ant hill you would look up
and you would see some of these galaxies
and nebulae um and suddenly everything
would uh would change rather as it
changes when you see the towers
and spires of sharks cathedral across an
open field in northern france that same
kind of impact that same collision of
your daily self with something you know
public so yeah if anyone who's owning
those uh uh those uh screens in times
square is watching let's let's plug them
into the hubble and talk a little bit
about the
you you have
you talk about travel you talk about
yeah communal restaurants
um
i'm interested in the travel business
because um travel is seen by religions
as an absolutely fundamental part of a
spiritual life
and that's interesting you know because
we travel a lot as well so you think
okay what what did they do and what do
we do you're talking about pilgrimages
yes pilgrimage exactly um
what is a pilgrimage a pilgrimage has
many things but it's it's really an
attempt to use a journey to help your
soul
uh and we kind of have an impulse in
that you say okay well i'm gonna go on a
journey to try and do something but
we're very unstructured about it we
don't really connect our destinations
with our inner needs the the real if you
look at the so-called travel pages of
newspapers
the dilemma is always how do i find the
hotel or how do i get a cheaper rate on
something the real question of travel is
how do i match
the outer world with some evolution in
the inner world that's what religion
that's how religion uses travel so i try
and imagine what a travel agency might
be like that have properly studied
religion and it's playful suggestion but
it's a real suggestion like many of my
suggestions and and really what you
would do is you would have
like you used to do in medieval
christianity before setting out on a
pilgrimage you would visit a priest and
you would discuss the state of your soul
and the priest would guide you to a
destination
he would literally have a map or a book
of destinations around europe and and
your inner life and your outer
destination would be matched plenty
there for the modern travel agent
and you might walk because again as
religions uh understand often the ease
of getting there undermines the capacity
of a journey to affect a change in us
there is in difficulty um a
uh metaphor for an inner difficulty and
so by removing all outer difficulties
you undermine our willingness to endure
an inner difficulty to change so
and the other problem is that people
leap having lived for 20 years in the
developing world
from
uh
you know a cloistered
industrial environment to to a
replication of that yeah in a resort i
mean in fact they don't travel at all
really yeah orwell wrote an essay about
this once yeah they don't travel at all
and um and they're they're genuine
rather touching ambitions that they do
you know people want serious things from
their travel they they travel in order
to find themselves in order to improve a
relationship in order to discover their
children in order to
understand the world these are really
really serious ambitions and yet how
often travel goes wrong you know because
these serious ambitions are not taken
seriously by the travel industry well
and it's the cruelty of marketing
absolutely where we can be so easily
dissuaded where these noble impulses can
be you know taken taken
you know that's going off to a club med
and it's going to be computers gonna
that's right that's right so that's
that's another area um
i also look at the area of community and
it strikes me that one of the things
religions are brilliant at doing is
bringing a group of strangers together
in an extraordinary accomplished
beautiful space and through certain
basic actions basically introduce
themselves they act as hosts and just
like a host at a party will break the
ice and allow people to release their
humanity and curiosity so a religious
host um does that with you know the
group of uh congregants um we've lost
that ability a city a modern city like
new york or anywhere is full of bars and
restaurants but these are corrupt
visions these are not communal spaces
they are simulacra of of of communities
no one really talks to anyone or only in
slightly haphazard ways
there is we we lack any systematic
mechanisms for turning the stranger into
a friend which is so core to all
religions all religions have the table
at which the stranger can come and can
eat and break bread
these are wonderful traditions uh we
spend so much time worrying about
restaurants and the quality of the you
know tomatoes there and you know it's
nonsense compared to the real ambition
of the table and i suggest in my book
you know let's get some tables where you
know it doesn't really matter what
you're going to eat the point is
friendship and community and that
ancient religious originally religious
ideal of breaking bread with a stranger
you don't talk about theater in the book
classical theater and i'm wondering uh
especially having lived in new york
after 9 11
and the whole build up to the iraq war
the the one institution
that sought to remind us of the horror
of war was not in fact the church
which pretty much signed on for the war
as an institution but theater
and there were
numerous productions uh supplement women
i mean all sorts of great stuff that
were done and theater itself has a kind
of sacred quality it gives it
it
you know in some kind of way almost
brings back to life our the past our
ancestors
it has a communal quality it has a
ritual i just wondered what your
thoughts were um
i accept all of that if i were to
criticize theater and a lot and in
relation to religion um certain
religious communal rituals have elements
of theater you know a mass et cetera but
it's not simply what um uh that
theorists i think it was uh bourdieu
called the society of the spectacle um
no it wasn't but it was kind of uh
guide to war it's dubai
exactly um what what dubois wisely
called the society of the spectacle um
he criticized modern culture
for extraordinary things happening on
the stage and all of us there like this
and he critic he compared this with
religious and pre-modern societies where
there's extraordinary stuff going on
stage and that has an impact on the
audience and you leave transformed and
with an energy to transform and i've
been in so many plays
wonderful moving plays where the
audience is wrapped and the audience is
ready to go anywhere that the play has
taken them anywhere we are in ecstasy we
are in a state of ecstasy and we are in
the hands of those actors
and then the curtain comes down and we
go and buy an ice cream and head out for
a taxi and go home
and that's it the whole thing
the energy that was in that theater that
could have transformed the world
it dissipates
and so um
you know i i look back to a more radical
theatrical tradition you know of brecht
and you know there are others who've
thought about this that theater should
not just exist in the playhouse that it
should maybe start in the playhouse but
that it's for you know everyone and that
tradition looked very much to religion
as an integration of
spectacle and public engagement
and yet in times of
repression
and i covered pinochet's chile
art
and theater
uh i mean the two major institutions
that stood up to pinochet were actually
the church and the theater
i think i think you're right i mean i
think people do walk out and are sort of
anesthetized
but that's because of the sort of
the culture that's upon them once
everything's stripped down i mean susan
sondag
went to sarajevo while it was being
shelled and surrounded and did waiting
for godot and that has a power to speak
whenever when all of those false
comforts are gone
i think often times the inability to
hear and see as you point out
is
uh
is the narcotic of well i think it comes
back to this idea of how seriously we
should take works of art and there's
this assumption that even though we pay
reverence to art and arts so important
etc we don't really want to allow it to
transform things
and whenever a very powerful work comes
along um just the way in which i don't
know there's just this um you don't
wouldn't one wouldn't want to call it a
conspiracy but it almost feels like a
conspiracy to to strip it of its truly
transformational uh power as i said you
know we all know films or plays you've
come out and you think i want to change
my life you know this piece of work has
urged upon me an agenda that is so
different from everything around but the
problem is that by lunchtime the next
day you've kind of forgotten it and you
know by the next weekend it's it's gone
and there's something new at the at the
theater and uh you know and and that's
it so we don't have follow-through and
again to look at religions religions are
all about circling they're saying
you know there were these insights there
were these powerful insights so we're
gonna go back to them because you know
you knew them on sunday but you'll
forget them by next saturday so we're
gonna go back to them and um
modern culture
it's almost like can't take its own high
points seriously enough it undermines
itself and this constant search for the
new the new is great because you keep on
good things in the new but this this
sort of um
this neglect of repetition and rehearsal
seriously undermines the capacity of any
one work of art to really affect change
when you have
as you certainly do with judaism and
christianity
systems of thought that were written by
an oppressed class
to what extent uh
is that theology aimed for the oppressed
um
i i was in a refugee camp in the war in
el salvador and they were decorating the
camp
for uh the day of the innocence which
and i knew the story i heard my father
reading the pulpit
and i asked one of the refugees why it
was such an important holiday and they
said because on this day
jesus became a refugee jesus had fled
with mary and joseph to egypt in
before herod came and killed the
children
and i who had heard the story from a
position of privilege in some
fundamental level had although i could
recite it verbatim didn't understand it
and i'm wondering uh you know if you
look at the antebellum south
you had two strains of the christian
religion you had black the black church
and you had the white slave holding
church which used the bible of course to
defend slavery
and uh i think there's a theologian
james cohen has made a pretty strong
argument that uh in many ways he
actually calls the white church and not
just the antebellum church but the white
church
he calls it the antichrist
because and he talks a lot about
lynching as sort of our modern cross
uh and i just wanted to you know as we
close if you could address that issue
that issue of justice that issue of
oppression and to what extent finally
religion
you know or religious theological
systems
in some ways pro may not have been
written for people like you and me
look i think there's something
immensely important in a message which
is there in all the major faiths which
is a defense
of the vulnerable the weak
the child
the dispossessed
and more broadly the self that exists
outside of power money and status all
religions are
at their purest
on the side of
that in a way on the side of the um the
status person
um
the secular world is a winner society
you know we live in capitalism
capitalism rewards productivity and
economic
merit and demonstrable economic success
this is an immensely punishing ideology
that leads to madness at its most
extreme because only a fraction of the
members of this planet and even the
members of the united states can ever
live up to that ideology
under that ideology
a huge portion of the world citizens and
american citizens are losers
and
that can't be right and where do the
losers go what what ideology is it that
has led half the population to be
defined as a loser this can't be the
right philosophy
and what religions have very cleverly
intelligently done is to say no that's
the wrong ideology that what matters is
not power and status and the possession
of vast castles but the inner self the
inner being the stuff that a parent
would love in a child
that
outside of power relationships when we
love outside of power relationships what
we love in people is the pure person and
that that's what matters and in
different forms that's what all the
religions say love the powerless love
the child love the weak person love the
mortal self
um not vanity not power etc and we need
that voice desperately and what saddens
me is that
it's really only the faiths that put
forward that voice articulately it used
to be put forward by marxism and by the
left
unfortunately the left was discredited
by all sorts of economic positions and
it failed to capitalize on really what
was its richest area which was its
emotional analysis of what we need by
focusing itself as a scientific economic
cure to the ills of mankind it fatally
shot itself in the foot so we're now in
a world where there's capitalism on the
one hand and faith-based organizations
on the other and what gives the
faith-based organization such strength
is that capitalism labels so many people
losers
i think
as the absolute ruler of the world if
ever i were i would say what we need is
a non-faith-based ideology which
recognizes the dignity and humanity of
the vulnerable and the weak and the
child
all right well thank you very much thank
you so much